now it's better to have loved and lost  than to have never loved at all right  at least that's what sports fans deep in  their feelings try to tell themselves as  their all-time favorite player puts on a  new uniform and looks ravishing the  blackhawks released pictures of  marc-andre fleury and his red chicago  threads and it will send a golden knight  fan spiraling it's like logging onto  facebook and seeing your ex from six  years ago married with kids  what have i done  fleury also debuted his new goalie  helmet it also takes your breath away  tell you what i'm i don't lose sleep  over the golden knights winning or  losing but seeing flurry as a blackhawk  i had to sit down brian fellas can you  assist john out of the studio  this is an emotional moment  we get it done